une attaque aérienne russe fait deux
morts et cinq blessés parmi les soldats
turcs dans la région d'idlib en série
annonce du ministère turc de la défense
des cibles des milices qui ont attaqué
les forces gouvernementales syriennes à
des groupes djihadistes soutenu par
ankara selon moscou qui appelle la
turquie a cessé de soutenir les
terroristes dans le secteur la
correspondance en russie tantôt
nucléaire antoine comment la russie
justifie t'elle ses frappes et bien le
ministère russe de la défense via le
centre pour la réconciliation des
parties en syrie a fait savoir que les
forces aériennes russes n'avaient en
fait fait que répondre à une demande des
autorités syriennes écouter le 20
février 2020 des bands armés terroristes
ont perpétré plusieurs attaques massives
au moyen de nombreux véhicules blindés
contre des unités gouvernementales en
direction de rémy nas nayrab à la
demande du commandement syrien
les avions sukhoï sous 24 d'efforts
aérospatiale de russie ont effectué des
frappes sur les bandes armés terroristes
qui avaient réalisé une percée afin de
les empêcher de s'avancer à l'intérieur
du territoire syrien
d'après le communiqué cette action a
permis aux troupes syriennes de
repousser ces attaques d'après le texte
d'après le texte ils demandent également
à la turquie je cite d'arrêter de
soutenir les terroristes et d'arrêter de
leur fournir des armes afin d'éviter de
futurs incidents après les menaces
d'offensive turc à idleb proférées par
recep tayyip erdogan il semble il semble
que l'on assiste à une nouvelle escalade
dans le nord ouest de la syrie d'où
l'importance pour les autorités russes
de relancer le dialogue pour apaiser les
tensions dans ce sens le porte parole du
kremlin dimitri peskov a fait savoir
hier qu'une réunion iran turquie russie
et est actuellement en préparation même
si à l'heure actuelle aucune date n'a
encore été arrêtée
merci anthony claireaux en direct
de moscou